bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette nouvelle petite vidéo en
direct en léger différé on va dire de la
ferme de abrams kral qui se trouvent en
afrique du sud à côté de la ville de
beaufort tout est en plein milieu du
caroux la ferme d'abraham ce graal c'est
un des hauts lieux de la paléontologie
du permien puisque c'est ici qu'ont été
découvert de nombreux appareils azor
dino céphale gorgone obtient 10
innovantes donc toute cette faune très
typique du permis à un moyen notamment a
été découvert dans les terrains qui se
trouve derrière moi donc ici on est sur
le site de la ferme qui est on va qui
est comme vous le voyez bien entretenues
voyez que l'herbe y est bien verte mais
là il faut pas vous laisser vous trompez
c'est le désert du karoo ici autour de
cette ferme ya rien sur des kilomètres
et des kilomètres donc là on a beaucoup
de chance d'être ici et du coup vu qu'on
est ici pour parler reptiles eh bien
parlons reptiles on a plein de reptiles
qui ont été découverts ici quoi donc
c'est l'occasion rêvée de cause et
reptiles et notamment de causer de la
question déjà
doit-on dire dinosaures ou dinosaures
non aviens doit-on dire reptiles ou sur
oxyde doit-on dire reptiles maliens ou
synapses il nomma malien bon bah c'est
ça fait partie de ces questions alors
les grands inquisiteurs de l'internet
évidemment vous diront non mais ces
dinosaures non aviens et rien d'autre
et justement voilà la grande question
quel est le quel est le mal à dire
dinosaures par rapport à dinosaures non
aviens bon bah c'est assez simple quand
on parle de dinosaures
généralement on veut parler des
dinosaures qui ont vécu pendant le
mésozoïque et qui était surtout connu
pour être des gros animaux évidemment
quand on pense d'innocents on pense pas
immédiatement aux petits dinosaures
comme microraptor etc on pense aux gros
dinosaures et ont poste et on ne pense
pas en fait aux oiseaux et les oiseaux
ils sont déjà là au mésozoïque
mais le mot dinosaures tels que l'emploi
dans le langage courant ne inclut pas
les oiseaux enac inclut même rarement
d'ailleurs les petits dinosaures qui
sont qui sont rattachés aux oiseaux donc
pour être plus précis on dit dinosaures
non aviens donc dinosaures non oiseaux
alors avec dinosaures non aviens à la
sauce a plutôt pris on est d'accord la
plupart des gens qui connaissent un
petit peu les dinosaures
vont vous dire que effectivement en
dinosaures non aviens ça marche mieux ça
devient plus compliqué quand on touche à
des des systèmes comme reptiles et
s'oxyde donc reptiles et ce en europe
s'il ya un énorme débat sur faut-il dire
reptiles ou sont oxydés même chez les
spécialistes il n'est pas réglé à savoir
que reptiles c'était un terme qu'on
utilisait autrefois pour parler des
crocodiles des lézards des serpents et
du ce fait nos dons
et son oxydes ben en fait ça inclut ça
plus les oiseaux donc c'est le clad en
fait la grande famille qui inclut tous
les descendants puisque les oiseaux
étant eux-mêmes descendants des
dinosaures sont eux mêmes des reptiles
donc ça c'est un secret pour personne le
problème c'est que même les spécialistes
sont pas capables de dire si on devrait
dire ce europe side ou reptile son
propre site c'est un terme inventé je
crois par des généticiens
relativement tard dans l'histoire des
sciences alors que reptiles c'est le
terme qui a été historiquement utiliser
qui a donc voix de priorité si on suit
le code de nomenclature internationale
donc doit-on dire reptiles ou sera aussi
la réponse est
on peut dire reptiles en précisant qu'
on inclut les oiseaux mais dans ce cas
là on fait une énorme périphrase voilà
je parle des reptiles en incluant les
oiseaux
donc utiliser son propre site ça semble
plus sensée mais ça c'est en violation
avec le code de nomenclature
internationale donc on ne sait pas si on
doit dire un reptile ou seront psid on a
le droit de dire les deux tant qu' on
est bien d'accord sur le fait que
reptiles doit inclure les oiseaux si
vous le dites si vous l'utilisez en tout
cas si vous voulez rester fidèles
avaient classification mais encore une
fois ça dépend le sens
si vous voulez parler de reptiles mais
en excluant les oiseaux comment vous
faites est ce que vous dites encore une
fois red team l'on a bien j'ai jamais
entendu en tout cas j'ai rarement
entendu les gens parler de victimes non
aviens de soro psymon à vient encore
pire donc
et l'assa 2 ça commence déjà quand le
terme quand l'utilisation du terme app a
été entérinée dans le langage courant ça
commence à sembler jargonneux en fait ça
commence à ressembler un peu à du du
pinaillage ça recommence à ressembler du
pinaillage donc et ça devient encore
pire encore encore pire quand on
commence à parler bain des poissons qui
ont donné les amphibiens et là il ya
déjà eu quatre 4 arrêts cardiaques dans
les commentaires les poissons qui ont
donné naissance aux amphibiens vous les
appelez comment ben va falloir sachant
que ces poissons se sont pas n'importe
quel poisson ce sont des sarko pts est
rien et que c'est sarko terry gien sont
en phase de transition vers la vers les
tétrapodes il faudrait parler de sarko
pts et rien ne monte et rapports voire
même de tétrapodes mans donc tétrapodes
et là ça commence à puer le jargon
là ça commence à sentir bon et et on va
parler lui aussi des synapses id donc
les synapses ide qui ont donné naissance
aux mammifères ben c'est pareil faudrait
les appeler des synappci non ma malien
est pareil c'est jargonneux à souhait
c'est absolument jargonneux à souhait et
quand vous vous adressez une audience de
gens qui ne savent pas de quoi vous
parlez qui connaissent rien à la
paléontologie ou à la classification il
ya des gens qui peuvent très bien
connaître la paléontologie sans rien
dépité à la classification aussi donc
c'est pas parce que vous êtes face à une
audience de qui connaît la paléontologie
que vous êtes forcément en terrain
conquis de ce point de vue là c'est que
utiliser des termes de classification
précis ça requiert d'avoir une audience
prêts à les encaisser et c'est là
exactement où on va répondre à la
question faut-il dire reptiles faut-il
dire dinosaures ou faut-il dire synappci
doux faut-il employer les termes
jargonneux c'est que tout dépend à qui
vous vous adressez en fait si vous vous
adressez à une audience de jean conquis
par la classification donc une audience
de spécialistes évidemment vous allez
utiliser des termes précis des termes
jargonneurs vous allez parler de sarko
pts érige yanon tétrapodes si vous le
voulez et si vous vous êtes devant une
audience de spécialistes détendue vous
allez dire des poissons les amphibiens
voilà parce que même les spécialistes de
toute façon quand on parle pas ici donc
abrams kral quand on parle de deux
terrab side ou de synapses id on ne
précise jamais rentrer nous non malien
le dire tous mes collègues ici on dit et
rapide et on sait très bien de quoi on
parle on précise jamais non malien parce
que c'est chiant à dire à chaque fois et
aussi parce que c'est faux c'est pas les
thérapies gnome malien cdt rapsim non
mali à forme dont on devrait parler en
réalité donc même les gens qui
pinaillent en disant non il était rapide
on affine les synopsis non non malien en
réalité ils pinaillent pour aurélien
parce que le vrai nom du clad qu'on est
sensé exclure scemama la forme donc on
devrait la thérapie menons malia forme
et on s'emmerde jamais faire ça parce
qu'on sait très bien de quoi on parle et
c'est ça la clé du truc c'est que tant
que tout temps que vous savez de quoi
vous parlez en fait vous pouvez employer
les termes que vous voulez l'important
en fait c'est la définition que vous
donnez donc s'il est très claire entre
vous et votre audience de quoi vous
voulez parler
eh ben c'est pas ça il y aura aucun
problème en fait c'est juste ça le truc
donc quand vous parlez dinosaures quand
vous parlez si la petite quand vous
parlez poisson qui se transforme en
amphibiens
l'important c'est que les gens sachent
de quoi vous parlez l'important c'est
que ce soit très clair entre vous et
votre audience que les termes que vous
employez désigne ce que vous voulez
qu'il désigne donc l'important c'est de
bien définir les termes quand vous
commencez à parler c'est à dire que si
vous voulez par les dinosaures mais pas
des oiseaux il suffit de bien préciser
aujourd'hui on va parler des dinosaures
qui vivaient au mésozoïque
et qui aimait pas des oiseaux voilà et
ensuite vous pouvez utiliser le terme
dinosaures sans préciser à chaque fois
non aviens s'avère aucun problème si
c'est un accord tacite ça même pas
forcément besoin d'être précisés 7,6 à
un accord tacite que aujourd'hui la
vidéo sera sur les dinosaures mais pas
les oiseaux je veux dire si vous avez
une chaîne qui est 100% focus sur la
paléontologie globalement le registre
fossile des oiseaux étant tellement
maigrichon quand vous parlez de
dinosaures c'est quasiment jamais des
oiseaux en réalité puisqu'il n'ya
quasiment pas de fossiles de toute façon
donc si votre chaîne parle de
paléontologie votre chaîne youtube je
veux dire où votre réseau social est
entièrement consacré à la paléontologie
bombard ou mésozoïque voilà vous n'avez
probablement jamais besoin de préciser
que vous parlez de dinosaures non aviens
parce que
parce que c'est compris par tout le
monde que vous parlez de ça donc ya pas
besoin de dire à chaque fois dinosaures
non aviens dans la mesure où
chacun sait de quoi on parle mais faut
que ce soit que r entre vous et votre
audience de quoi vous parlez par exemple
moi quand je donne des cours sur les
synappci donc là je repars sur les
synapses id je parle le synaps id sans
jamais dire dans ma malia forme et ça se
voit même j'utilise le terme reptiles
malien donc là ça c'est encore un autre
débat encore plus intéressant le terme
reptiles ma malien dont qui désigne les
synapses id non mammadyarov le synaps in
qui ne sont pas des mammifères ou des
proches parents des mammifères très
direct donc les synapses il nomma malia
forme les reptiles malien il ya beaucoup
de gens qui me disent ah reptiles mamma
mia faut arrêter de dire c'est pas bien
c'est un mauvais termes c'est honteux
faut jamais dire ça alors généralement
ce qu'ils veulent c'est que je remplace
par le mot prémat malien alors préparez
lien ça veut dire en gros avant les
mammifères ça veut dire que les reptiles
malien n'existerait que pour donner
naissance aux mammifères donc c'est pas
beaucoup mieux de dire prémat malien
en tout cas ça a un sens et c'est
toujours pareil les mots ont un sens et
le mot reptiles la combinaison reptiles
mavs ayala sens très précis ce sont des
animaux qui essentiellement dans leur
biologie sont reptilien c'est à dire
qu'ils pondent des oeufs qu'ils avaient
une posture rampante et qu'ils avaient
des écailles et on sait que la plupart
avaient des écailles en tout cas on est
à peu près sûr qu'avant les mammifères y
a rien qui avait des poils donc ça déjà
c'est réglé vos représentations des
thérapies side normalien avec des
moustaches s'avoue l'oublier c'est faux
en tout cas dans l'état actuel des
connaissances c'est faux non seulement
on n'a jamais trouvé de synappci la
moustache pas de cynapsys dans ma
manière moustache de reptiles ma manière
à moustache mais en plus on a de bonnes
raisons de penser qu'ils n'avaient pas
de poids donc les eaux toutes les
représentations de reptiles mama lien
avec des poils ou avec des moustaches
vous pouvez les oublier reptiles malien
du coût de ce point de vue là est
beaucoup plus voici que la plupart des
paléo art que vous verrez sur internet
rétine malien ça désigne annan mal donc
qui est un reptile c'est à dire
essentiellement dans sa biologie il pond
des oeufs il il a une posture rampante
et il a des écailles en tout cas elle a
pas de poils et donc reptile est un
terme précis pour les désigner tout dont
leurs squelettes alors rooms théologie
c'est pas étonnant lorsque l'être rien
ou quasiment rien net en commun avec les
mammifères par contre ça ressemble
beaucoup à des reptiles moderne
et maliens pour souligner le fait qu'ils
sont reliés phylogénétiquement aux
mammifères et voilà mais je veux dire
par le terme reptiles ma valeur vous
avez une définition parfaite de ce
qu'est ainsi l'abside non mabaya forme
pourquoi se passer du timbre et petits
maliens à la raison pour laquelle on
veut s'en passer c'est que quand vous
faites un cours de philo génétique c'est
plus précis des synapses id normalien
forme mais la plupart du temps quand
vous parlez de la petite manière vous
parlez pas phylogénétique vous parler de
leur biologie
donc c'est pareil quand vous vous
adressez à une audience de non
spécialistes ou à autre chose que des
étudiants en philo génétique
utiliser autre chose que les petits vins
malien c'est pas que ça n'a pas de sens
mais c'est sarah prend un autre sens en
fait
c'est à dire que vous accordez
énormément d'importance à une
classification alors que vous n'êtes par
là alors que vous n'êtes pas là pour
parler classification donc en fait vous
faites un hors sujet
c'est à peu près ça l'idée c'est pour ça
que je disais au départ la définition
c'est important la définition par
rapport à notre audience c'est important
définissez les termes quand vous les
employés la première fois et tout ira
bien identifier correctement votre
audience et employer les termes qui l'en
qui leur correspondent reptiles malien
n'est pas un gros mot reptiles malien
désigne des animaux à la biologie
essentiellement reptilienne merlhiot
mammifères c'est un très beau terme pour
désigner
les synapses il amphibiens les premiers
tétrapodes était d'amphibiens dans leur
biologie vous pouvez dire
amphibiens sans aucun sens aucune honte
on parlait de ses tétrapodes l'onda
mignotte il avait il il vivait
essentiellement dans l'os avait une
reproduction qui était essentiel qui
était lié à l'eau in il n'avait pas des
cayes en tout cas pour autant qu'on
sache et et ils avaient pour la plupart
des métamorphoses beaucoup d'entre eux
se métamorphosent exactement comme les
en filière moderne le font donc
biologiquement parlant c'était des
amphibiens et lorsque l'être à tout d'un
squelette d'amphibiens donc dans le
fossile ça se retranscrit aussi par
contre si vous parlez classification là
vous allez vous devoir dire peut-être un
peu non amiotte et si vous voulez être
précis dans les termes de classification
avec une audience qui est sensible à ça
vous avez utilisé tétrapodes mon amiante
et pareil pour reptiles reptiles pour un
paléontologue ça désigne tous les âmes
note qui ne sont ni des mammifères ni
les oiseaux donc tous les amis hautes
normes amalia forme et non à venir pour
un paléontologue sont des reptiles
pourquoi parce que quand on trouve leurs
fossiles ici
on retrouve des fossiles qui ont des os
qui est qu'on ne retrouve pas chez les
oiseaux et chez les mammifères actuels
mais qu'on retrouve chez les reptiles
moderne donc voilà c'était juste une
petite vidéo pour rappeler qu'en fait
les mots ont un sens même les termes qui
semble désuet aujourd'hui ont un sens il
avait un sens et vous tous nos relations
sont aujourd'hui est que vous pouvez
utiliser ce sens dans un but de
vulgarisation et de toute façon c'est ce
qu'on fait à longueur de temps qu'on
fasse cours des conférences ou qu'on
parle à nos amis ont fait de la
vulgarisation on essaie de faire
comprendre ce qu'on dit et il ya des
termes qui permettent de faire
comprendre très facilement les choses
par les deux dinosaures ce n'est pas un
gros mot de par les dinosaures ou de
parler de dinosaures non aviens ce n'est
pas un gros mot c'est si vous parlez à
vos parents de si vous êtes
paléontologue et vous essayez
d'expliquer ou passionnés paléontologie
et vous expliquez à vos parents
les dinosaures non aviens
et vous regarder mais pourquoi pourquoi
tu précises bournat vient ça veut dire
quoi bien parce que encore pour nous ça
marche nous on est européen et on a une
culture latino gréco latine avec des
mots qui ont une très forte étymologie
dans la langue dans les langues grecque
et latine mais ici en afrique du sud
c'est pas le cas du tout voilà plupart
des langages locaux ici ils ont aucune
étymologie qui se rapproche de près ou
de loin du grec et du latin donc c'est
vous ne pouvez pas utiliser dinosaures
non aviens en espérant ici que les gens
vont comprendre ce que à bien veut dire
donc vous utilisez dinosaures parce que
de toute façon vous savez très bien que
quoi qu'il arrive vous parler de la même
chose pour conclure vous pouvez employer
amphibiens feu poissons reptiles
dinosaures sans jamais préciser la
teneur de la classification mais pour ça
il faut d'une identifier votre audience
choisir le terme en fonction de cette
audience et vous assurer que la
définition des termes que vous avez
choisi est bien accepté par tout le
monde et tout ira bien vous pouvez
parler de vos reptiles en toute sécurité
voilà c'était julien en direct du caroux
et je vous dis à très bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo salut